what's going on here because you guys
are traveling together you're still
living you're doing a show i mean this
is not this we're we're just you're
welcome but not lovers i think that
we're like deep we're mindfully and
lovingly breaking up
breaking up doesn't have to be this
thing like [ __ ] that [ __ ] or all this
stuff there's no chance of a reunion
i don't know i don't
i mean it's not my it's not my plan
right now but no like if it's if it's
you know in the books for us down the
future then then great but if not like
one way or the other is it not difficult
to spend so much time together no you
guys don't have any resentment between
the two of you i don't know wow and you
guys are comfortable like go doing these
long drives together like as platonic
friends apparently we are we did it well
that's very interesting well is it i
don't know we spent whole days together
we spent whole days together and is
there any physical intimacy still no
that's a lie
what do you mean we're not having sex
but we're still like some you know
there's like no we don't do this holding
we do can we show him the friendship
yeah i do hold your hands in public but
we do it like this
it doesn't seem like a breakup
it is you guys are holding hands in
public she was an academy in [ __ ] uh
withdrawal is that was that ketamine
associated she was like i can't walk she
goes well that's when you hold me and
i'm like
[ __ ] this [ __ ]
yelled after me it means i did it not
true
we accidentally held hands we forgot
that we were holding hands and then we
broke it we broke away when we realized
like why are we holding hands
if it was ketamine related i understand
but you made it sound like you guys just
go cruise around holding hands no we
don't
accidentally sometimes and you and do
you guys sleep in different rooms now no
same bed no same bed okay that's a
little odd it's not
not
really isn't you guys sleep in the same
bed
yeah and we watch uh movies together at
night and do you guys ever like cuddle
no oh we stay side by side
uh no but we're when we watch a movie on
his ipad we're about like we're pretty
close
wow
in the same bed
what's the problem pal i don't think
that's normal after a breakup yeah maybe
in your twisted little world i just
think there's still something happening
no because in i've talked to my
therapist the one that i canceled today
for you
it's now exactly and now and then
and now it's just another thing that
we're throwing the resentment bucket we
scheduled this two weeks ago bro
okay i didn't these guys did and did not
yell at you the other day oh so you
weren't even happy about it
normally i would i don't know why you
bring this out of me but normally i
would say normally i would cancel it
right but you keep bringing it up this
time i did it obviously anyway let's go
let's go back like a it's not like a
compliment like you think it is it's
like another thing in the resentment
bucket against tricky jew ethan
right
so
so um to answer your stupid question
right
is
we're mindfully doing it within a loving
way you know eventually she's going to
find her own place okay right
preferably somewhere near me so i can
see the dogs easier
right
um we we're going to work together right
and i like hanging out her family is
like my family so that's never going to
change
okay
um and you know but by you crying with
your little no tricky mind oh you know
what i mean and you i don't know
anything about it i know you guys broke
up and i was i'm naturally curious but
if you're uncomfortable i won't push it
anymore and i just want to say this but
i'm not you brought up the the the thing
that the gotcha thing let's just go what
like we're going to let you guys the
thing that you when you we came onto
your show right and you said you brought
up the
the schwab
see i don't even want to say it but yeah
that well let's not pretend like it
didn't happen yeah it did happen when
you brought that up we didn't know that
you were gonna bring that up so what i
i understand that but what i'm saying is
is that that's what you are
no dude no you're not a gotcha guy no
it's not true
i have to be honest with you dude it did
ask her for that day i didn't like you
i was actually it wasn't i thought you
think i know but i was so angry first of
all let me let it's like okay and then
with the mole thing after that it's just
like exactly gotcha i knew it's a double
gotcha so my point is is that double
guess
i'm trying to let it go
interviews there is no resentment but
you're bringing it out so i'm just
saying i love you no it's good you're
getting it out there yeah